Speaker 1: Hey, I want to talk about, you know,
sometimes we sometimes we focus on the wrong thing
and we miss the forest for the trees. When we
talk about a story, it can happen to any of us.
And there was an incredible series of videos from
New York City in which hundreds of Proud Boys,
this right wing group committed a crime,
an infraction we can call it, for which
black teens in New York City for lack of a better
term. And I saw it. Have, you know, when I was
on the subway all the time pre-pandemic, I
would see it all the time. Black teens will
often get arrested by NYPD for doing something
that hundreds of Proud Boys did over the weekend,
which is they jumped the turnstiles. They
went in through an exit door on the subway and
literally nothing happened. I'm going to
play this video here for our video audience,
and you see that there are just dozens and
dozens and multiple videos of these Proud Boys.
On the New York subways
Speaker 4: and over there,
Speaker 1: and someone says it's open
and then you start to see these guys
pour in through what is supposed to be an exit
door. This is called jumping turnstiles. You're
not always literally jumping turnstiles.
Very often. It was like as I was leaving,
I would push open the exit and people
would slip in and you see them here.
Now, civil rights attorney and longtime public
defender Scott Hechinger tweeted about this and
said As a public defender, I represented literally
hundreds of black men and women accused of doing
this. Most literally couldn't afford a $2 in
75 cents subway fare. The difference between
eating and not eating for them arrested, caged,
forced to plea to the crime of theft of services.
But when you're white and proud, right,
these proud boys, at least in these videos,
exclusively white. So is it only a racial issue?
No. But there's a big racialized component to
this. And the turnstile jumping used as a
justification to detain young black men on the New
York subway is a story almost as old as the subway
itself. For a comparison, we do have video of
how New York City police deal with some of these
other folks. And we have video we're showing here
where you see a group of police officers. They
are determined to find the turnstile jumpers.
And as we follow the camera, you see multiple
officers get on a subway car and they start. They
actually pull out Tasers in this case, and they're
pushing around. One guy believed to have been
turnstile jumping and it's really depressing, and
one two three four five six seven eight officers
and a scuffle begins. Anyway, you guys know
the story. You guys know the story. So this
is just another one of these cases where we see it
and we say, what? What is going on here? What is
the explanation here and why are there just dozens
and dozens of Proud Boys pouring in the exit door
jumping turnstiles? And everything's very,
very calm. You tell me if there's a different
explanation, I'm glad to see it, but this is a
classic classic that I witnessed 10 times, I guess
dozen or so times when I was on the subway all
the time before the pandemic just haven't really
been using public transit since the start
of the pandemic, but something very much to
think about. Interesting, just little tidbit
from the Proud Boy protests over the weekend.
Let's take a quick break. I do want to talk
about Ron DeSantis after this short break
and a bunch of other things. Glad you're with
me today on this shortened Thanksgiving week.